foreign
it is time for everybody's favorite I
literally think this is nobody's
favorite for the lightning round it's
Kelly's favorites
me late night dive bar music
yeah I'd like a bush draft on draft what
is it
I'd like Bush lightning on draft is is
that a thing I I don't know
no Kelly's like no those are back in the
old days I'm not real sure that
sounds like you're like Miller Lite on
tap well there is to me it's like you
know Coors Light In A Bottle or
something like that that's TBR to me oh
there we go PBR no because PBR is ironic
PBR is like Weezer now there's like a
hipster thing yeah it's like really
tight jeans and mustaches for people
Natty light Natty light and if you on
tap that's that music yes and a marble
red just because you have to
you can't you can't drink Natty light
and just have it be in your body you
have a package exactly it's a two for
one all right so here we are lightning
round
so we got through the old disgusting
beers yes welcome 2023. all right let's
do it so this uh lightning round is
about goals and resolutions how fitting
and cute I may have been planned maybe
maybe yeah it's my favorite time I love
it I know everybody gets a start to do
over oh no all right question one are
you ready Ben with the timer
what's the difference between goals and
resolutions
um I I tend to
um believe resolutions are about an
identity change I am I'm resolving too
take care of better care of my body I am
resolving to
um be a better husband I'm resolving
those kind of I resolved this year to be
on time uh a goal is
I will
um leave my house by 7 15 every day I
will lose 25 pounds by February 1st
forever so goals are these tangible
markers on the way to a resolution
that's what I look at it
I like that I ever thought of it that
way you're so smart oh no that one guy
called me intelligent earlier let's go
with smart let's start
all right second one I want to read more
next year how can I get into a good
habit
um
uh three things number one change your
identity I'm a person who reads that's
who I am and then create some behaviors
are going to back that up so leave your
phone in your car take a book in with
you when you go to Walmart
um and you're waiting for your oil to
get changed
um always always I've got I always have
a book on me at all times 24 7 365 and
even I have one when I'm hunting in the
woods I got a book in my bag like I
always have a book with me
um because one of my identities is I'm a
guy that reads the third thing is is
make it easy
um have a book by your bed have a book
by have your reading environment already
set up so it's not so hard and then I
think the fourth thing would be
um even if you can only read half of a
page a day
you're eventually going to get through a
book and so just because you don't have
two hours to read or I was going to read
an hour this morning then I got up late
cool read for five minutes just read
every single day and over time if you're
a reader
um you'll get through more books and
you'll begin reading more and more and
more you'll create that space
practice that's a better word awesome
best advice for new Dads going into the
new year
man the best advice I could give new
dads the advice that saved me was not a
hack or not a hey you should it was
getting a couple of dads who were five
ten years ahead of me 15 years ahead of
me that I could call and reach out to
and ask questions about the second thing
is is your experience as a dad is very
different than your
Partners experience so listen
stop ex explaining your experience as
the only experience going on in your
home somebody else is having a totally
radically different experience so commit
to listening so get some mentors get
some people not just some friends who
are further along down the road they'll
roll their eyes and laugh at you or
they'll be like that's not a big deal or
no you need to stop that right now you
need to get on that one right now and um
start listening more ta-da yeah
all right every year I set a goal to
work out more but I never stick to it
how do I actually follow through
uh
um
my workout honestly I can just say about
me personally
um it shifted when
I had a total it was a
it was a more Global conversation with
myself again you hear me say this all
the time change your identity I I just
decided I was gonna be a guy that took
better care of his body I wanted to be a
a Granddad or a great Granddad that
could roll around with my grandkids on
on our wrestling match when I was 90.
and so what I have to do right now I got
to stop eating the way I eat I gotta
start sleeping I gotta start doing some
of these other things and so exercise
became one piece of a much larger puzzle
it wasn't that I was just like eating
McDonald's every day and I was staying
up all night and I was laid everywhere
and then I tried to add working out that
never works it had to be a part of a
bigger shift
um the second thing is is it didn't
really change for me until I got
um some things at my house that I could
do and for me it started with a jump
rope and a couple of kettlebells maybe
some dumbbells
um and then I moved on to like the squat
rack I got off Craigslist and then I
moved on to another thing and then
another thing and now I've got a whole
set at my house but I made it really
easy
so if I could just do five minutes I'm
just gonna go do five minutes and that
morphed into what it is today
I want to change my eating habits this
year breaking the cycle of eating more
that I need or lots of sweets where do I
start
um I have had my whole life
revolutionized with the carbon app and
so I'd reach out to those guys Dr Lee
Norton and that crew get on the App
Store I make no money off this deal it's
just been something that's been really
helpful for me it it is hard
on Friday night or Saturday at a party
to try to figure out I hate it like I
hate not only hate the app I hate
learning how to be intentional about
what I eat but um until you I mean you
change what you measure right and until
you track and measure what you're
actually eating all the time it's really
hard to be like I'm just gonna think
about eating differently you gotta
actually follow it and carbon app is the
best of the best of the best
it's worth the money
when it comes to goals I start off
strong and then lose Steam how do I stay
motivated and accountable
as you're asking that I was gonna say
um have some people that keep you
accountable in your life and your this
is from James clear you're only as good
as your systems you're not you can't
always rely on your goals you're only as
good as the systems you've set up for
yourself and so
um if every day you get off of work and
you don't have dinner plans already or
every day you leave for work and you
have it meal prepped well you're at the
mercy of your calendar of whatever
they're cooking down in the cafeteria
what friend comes by and says hey let's
go get lunch somewhere you're at the
mercy of everybody else and so you're
only as good as your systems and so if
you want to change the way you eat you
just got to start with with I mean if
you want to change your goals you just
got to be highly intentional about the
systems you set up to make those goals
very easy like going back to talking
about reading carry a book with you
everywhere it makes wanting to read more
so much easier if you always have a book
on you foreign what happens when you
reach the goals you've set and then you
feel lost
um that's usually somebody that's
um yeah has not gone with the identity
shift they've just made a bunch of goals
and they thought when I cross a Finish
Line then my dad's going to call me out
of the blue and say you know what I'm
proud of you when I finally make six
figures I make a hundred thousand
dollars in a year then my old high
school girlfriend's gonna call and be
like I never should have left and you'll
be like I know and I'm gonna hang up
um
as soon as I finally lose 40 pounds then
finally that old boyfriend is gonna call
and be like
I saw your photos on Facebook you're so
that's never gonna happen that actually
might because men are disgusting but
like there's this idea that when I
accomplish a set of goals I'm gonna feel
a certain way
and it simply doesn't play out like that
the data says that
so many attorneys who make partner
actually have a fall off they feel like
I give up my 20s and 30s for this like
this is what I gave up for and so shift
your identity first this is who I am and
here's why
and that has a much longer
um then you're on you're on an adventure
you're not just trying to hit hit a
marker
that makes sense I feel like I was
rambling a little bit on that one but I
hope that makes sense I think it does
okay yeah
although we did think that the when your
ex-girlfriend calls you and says she
never should have broke up was very
oddly specific I'm just Hey listen
listen that's for another episode I
haven't run that by my wife I can tell
those stories yet one day all right next
question how do I help my teenagers
learn to set goals
foreign
teenagers watch you
and so if you are a disciplined person
who creates identity I would suggest
everybody this start this New Year with
an identity board here's who we are as a
family that goes on the board I mean
somewhere in your house it's prominent
uh here's who we are and then they watch
you live them
and then you provide opportunity for
them to live into them as well
but until they see you do it I mean
you're just you're just
I almost said pissing in the wind but I
thought better about it now so I didn't
say it
ta-da
apparently we need to work on how
microphones work
anywho all right yes how do I encourage
my spouse to stay on top of their goals
if I was your spouse I wouldn't want to
work on my goals if that was your
attitude
um honestly you can't you can't you can
only control you
um you can be very disciplined in taking
care of yourself and making sure that
you are are creating space where people
feel
um where their needs are met I guess the
one thing you could do and as I'm
thinking this out loud you can
ask what do you need from me to make it
possible for you to be able to do the
things that you need to do to stay well
and so I've got a series of things in my
house that I that I keep like if I see
dishes in the sink then I try to just
stop what I'm doing and just knock them
out because I know that gives my wife
not only five minutes of doing the
dishes but it gives her 10 minutes of
thinking about it and then she has to
schedule it between grabbing the kids
and doing it and so it just it ends up
the domino effect ends up opening a lot
of her day so what can I do to help meet
your your needs so that you can help
take care of yourself but other than
that I can't make anybody nagging
complaining those things never ever ever
work in fact they cause the opposite
all right last one what are the goals
you and your team have set for 2023
what are y'all's goals
check me everybody looked down like
it was like the math teacher like all
right we're going to talk about
equations and everyone just like looks
at the floor hoping they don't get
called on
am I going first I'll go first okay
um I I never really do goals I just I
maybe because you are the associate
producer of this show now you have to I
know I know I have to Let's that still
goes up okay well I have I have one in
my find of what I want to do it's just
the following through part that I always
Trail off you know I'm in that group of
like oh I set big goals January come
February 1st they're gone okay so we'll
see but I have never really had like a
nightly or a morning routine and I find
that I just feel tired and dragged
through the day because like I get up in
the morning and I just hit snooze like
10 times and then I get up and I rush
through getting ready I don't eat
breakfast and I go out the door so I'd
like to develop some sort of structure
where I have like okay by this time I'll
do this and then I eat breakfast because
you know apparently that's important
um and see if it helps my like
um my energy levels throughout the day
that's a pretty long goal so what if we
instead of focusing on that goal first
what what is an identity that goes
beyond that
I don't know
like I want to be the best
version of myself I can be I'm a person
who
shows up at work ready to go yes I think
so I because I I find myself in the boat
of like I get here at like 805. you know
like I just want to be able to be
somebody who gets to work
at a prompt time and I have like a set
schedule but you see how all those
things work together so yes maybe it's I
am a person who wants to show up at work
ready to rock and roll
um and so backing that up we all know
that like hitting snooze has a whole
biochemical Cascade that just it ruins
your day it really does it does and so
does not it may be for some of people
not eating breakfast and not exercising
and not whatever the series of steps are
right
um but I'm just the kind of woman who
shows up ready to rock and roll that's a
different that's a new Jenna
do what we're going to be clipping that
I'm just the kind of woman that shows up
ready to rock and roll by the way
John deloney that's on the Internet it's
now on the internet we already put it up
there
awesome awesome
uh all right I I uh anybody else
uh I wasn't prepared to answer this
question but one thing is that I my goal
is to finish my novel okay this year and
so the identity piece that you're
talking about is that I am a writer a
person that writes and so in order to do
that I have to write ah because writers
write every day yes and so like George
RR Martin
he's written great stuff I don't
consider him a writer because he doesn't
sit down right you know I'm saying we're
still waiting on that 10th book or
whatever yes Stephen King writes two
thousand words a day every day and so
he's a writer he's got a new book every
day that's right I'm ready to go so and
so in 2023 Ben is a writer yes fantastic
yes and manifesting it
the lead singer of dump button all right
um ours has been or mine my husband and
I have been working on
changing our identity around
Health health-wise
um and we've uh he's had some health
issues that have affected our lives in
our marriage and we have decided we
really want to change that so we want to
be a couple that
um
that is healthy and that travels and
that we will have an empty nest here in
about two years somewhere in the next
couple years and we want to be able to
go and do things
um and not be held back by that so we're
we did which uh what you talked about
earlier we have outfitted our bonus room
upstairs for everything we need
um with weights and the rowing machine
and all of that stuff and we're slowly
starting to do some things the last
couple weeks have kind of knocked us off
kilter a bit so just being intentional
about
um about our habits and supporting each
other more than that which we haven't
always done
so I love love the idea of saying okay
we got two years to empty nesters
to
celebrate and grieve being empty nesters
we're going somewhere and we want to be
able to do the following things there
and so how much money do do we need to
have 24 months out how much
um if we're going to be hiking we gotta
be in this kind of shape right we want
to have this kind of boom chicka wow so
I want it right whatever and so like I
love the idea of just simply putting on
a calendar in reverse engineering it
doesn't sound as sexy as let's just go
to Italy and like yeah that's just not
how the world Works only in Hollywood
that would be incredible I mean you set
yourself up for 24 months they're gonna
be tough and hard and a trip that's
going to be incredible
they're good for you
thanks
all right
um
Andrew's just staring down all right
here's here's uh I'll just I'll I'll
save you
um all right here's mine
um
one two three four five I got six
categories here
um two supersede the category supersede
all the categories one is
um
pathologically
insanely on time always
forever I'm making that my number one
priority
um and so I have to reverse engineer
every other part of my life to go
through that funnel weirdly that means
that I have to turn my phone off the
night before and I can't turn it back on
until I'm at work because I just find
myself done a Vortex
um
Etc et cetera et cetera I will have to
be pathologically on time that means I'm
gonna have to be very early to things
for a long time until I practice and
learn the second thing is the Simplicity
anti-clutter anti-chaos as I've been
working and writing this new book on
creating a non-anxious life
I keep coming to the literature that
talks about how clutter and all the crap
we have at our houses just are burying
us
um how much we always have headphones in
our ears uh all those things so
anti-clutter and anti-chaos simplicity
Simplicity Simplicity Simplicity
um next is more adventures and that's
everything from concerts to late night
trips to hunting trips to travel I'm
just gonna go be more adventurous
um I found myself getting kind of boring
and so we're just gonna go take a
midnight run and we're gonna go do
something fun
um loneliness I found myself really
lonely after all the travel and writing
this year so uh friends connection doing
things with new folks making new friends
my wife and I have some internal like we
want to continue to be the best married
couple we can be and so we're gonna have
some very direct goals about sex and
intimacy and that means we talk about it
openly which is kind of part of the fun
um we have some financial goals some big
things we want to buy and say for et
cetera and then for work um and I'd
guess the goals for our team
man to blow the lid off this show off
both the podcast and the YouTube show
and to make some really remarkable leaps
in how many people were able to just
serve and help
um across the globe and the show's just
grown like crazy this year and that's a
hundred percent thanks to you all
listening
um and the goal now is to start 2x 3x 5x
10xing at all and we've got some cool
things coming down the way that I think
are going to get us there so thank you
so so much
um for sticking with us this is the New
Year's episode who are you gonna be this
year
who are you going to be and what are the
things you're going to do on a daily
basis a weekly monthly basis they're
going to get you tour they're gonna
direct you towards the person you want
to become